let's talk about porn addiction because
some people in the comments section i
was very ecstatic about talking about
porn addiction i wonder why but so were
they orgasmic about talking yeah well
they were on a different website and
they just jumped on this uh and that
different website we'll talk about here
in a minute
psychology today porn addiction more
than 90 of young men report watching
porn videos with some regularity
particularly in the united states
apparently u.s kids like porn more than
other states many of these videos depict
acts that might never engage in
themselves in other words erotic
fantasies on pornhub the world's largest
porn website alone well over 90 billion
videos are viewed daily
by more than 64 million visitors
apparently 90 billion with only 7
billion people living here apparently
aliens are watching this i don't know
what's going on with that number
64 million visitors daily
26 of them are women females although
viewing erotica is nearly uh ubiquitous
among males some men and women regard
watching internet porn as pathological
and believe that at some time spent
doing so may be a sign of porn addiction
although such a diagnosis is rejected by
many psychologists and our treatment
approaches based on addiction models so
it continues to talk about all these
other things on why
it's good and why it's bad what are your
thoughts on porn addiction have you done
any kind of research on that or i did
research this is an amazing young guy
now what is research does research mean
you sit there for weeks watching
porn addiction foreign
researcher you guys should have on this
fantastic guy called alexander rhodes
who was part of my research we did not
masturbate together i want to stress uh
he's in pittsburgh he he runs a site
called nofap which is uh
no fap yeah yeah that he he became uh
obsessed with with porn so there's a few
things we're thinking about in relation
to porn it's a bit like video games i'm
not anti-porn right
pawn will meet a certain basic itch we
all watch it sometimes i don't take an
anti-pawn position
um there's a lot of itches going on
you've been telling my itching powder it
fixes it
yeah exactly people are confused listen
that's his english he uses folks he's
not saying anymore
you could tell from my word downton
abbey accent yeah the um but you know
it's interesting i went to the first
ever internet rehab center in the world
it's a place called restart washington
yeah it's just outside spokane
and it's so interesting so they get all
all sorts of people in this internet
rehab center but they disproportionately
get young men who become obsessed either
with online role-playing games or with
porn
and it was so fascinating talking to
these
particularly
spoke to the young men a lot but also dr
hilary cash who uh set up and runs a
click he's a really wise person
i remember her saying to me afterwards
she said you know you've got to and this
relates to your video game thing as well
she said you've got to ask yourself
what are these young men getting out of
these games right or we can think about
this in relation to porn so they're
getting something they used to get from
the culture but they no longer get so
they're getting with the video games
a sense they're physically roaming
around we've talked about that young
people don't get to do that
they get a sense they're good at
something we have a culture that does
not make young men think they're good at
anything a particular school system
but what they get is almost like a kind
of parody of those things and i started
to think about it in relation to porn as
well
because
in a way i think the relationship
between so the relationship between
social media and social life is a bit
like the relationship between porn and
sex
i'm not anti-porn at all
but if your whole sex life consisted of
just wanking over porn
you go around pretty pissed off and
grouchy all the time because we didn't
evolve to masturbate over screams we
evolved to actually have sex right no
one after an hour looking at porn feels
satisfied the way they do after having
sex at least if it weren't right
um
so i think there's a degree to which um
what's the context in which this
addiction is occurring right
the context is a context in which
young men are often made to feel
incompetent they're often made to feel
they're not good at anything
often made to feel frustrated like if
you look at what's happened with the the
in the wider economy um
a lot of particularly working-class
people
cannot earn enough to feel they can
provide for a woman for a family right
there's no city in the united states
where a minimum minimum wage worker can
rent a one-bedroom apartment not one
there's none
so i think if you create a sense of
humiliation among young men that makes
them less appealing to women
it makes women less interested in them
um
that can you can see how that's a kind
of environment where porn addiction
begins to develop and i want to
distinguish very clearly between someone
who looks at porn every now and then and
you know just to chill out or release
some stress and people who become
addicted that's a very different thing
just like we all know if we go into the
nearest bar to here
most people there are going to be
drinking alcohol to have a good time and
there's going to be a small minority who
have an alcohol addiction problem who
deserve love and compassion so i think i
would always wonder with every addiction
you always want to look at what's the
context
in which this addiction is occurring
what's the problem the person is trying
to solve what's the pain that they're in
that they're trying to not be present
with so in a way if you think about the
addictive behavior as almost like the
surface phenomena you want to deal with
what's the deeper question here oh
you're lonely 41 of americans agree with
the statement no one knows me well right
this is the loneliest society in human
history
and one study
has asked people for a good few years
how many close friends do you have you
could turn to in a crisis and when they
started doing it years ago the most
common answer was five today the most
common answer is none right now a lonely
society is going to be a society where
people are going to find opioids more
appealing they're going to find just
jerking off over pornhub more appealing
they're going to find
you know obsessively doing it if you're
cut off from the normal
necessities of life if your
psychological needs aren't met you're
going to be more vulnerable to addiction
whether it's porn cannabis whatever
there's two comments i want to give
credit to one of them i don't understand
the other one i think
one of them says
uh uh he says uh david jones is his name
porn made my ten year old mind think if
i did not look and perform like john
holmes i was a failure
what a travesty right
and larry medina says my socks are
pretty satisfying
so uh mysterious comment i i think
there's a separate question about kids
seeing porn and i definitely think we
don't want to be in a situation where i
mean i remember speaking about going to
the woods i remember when we were kids i
remember the first time i ever saw paul
when i was 11 years old german people
used to leave poor magazines in the
woods i don't know what the [ __ ] that
was about
and i remember i didn't like put out a
little magazine every like a handful of
meters yeah i was that lure you're into
their little pedophiles
i remember seeing what i saw was like
very very soft core
um and i remember not seeing it again
until i was i guess i found my brother's
porn when i was like 14 or something
i've got an older brother
but
the difference between that you do not
want your son's eight you don't want him
in a couple of years to be discovering
his first understanding of sex to be
[ __ ] gangbangs on porn up right so i
do think there's a lot to be done with
uh regulation when it comes to children
and there are some countries that have
done it so you have to opt in so you can
see porn on your broadband option uh
which i think would embarrass a lot of
people but who cares so that you you
know there are all sorts of ways you can
block these things for kids
we definitely don't want kids to be
learning about sex from porn because
porn is not uh
you know mo the vast majority of paul is
not a healthy or realistic you tell the
story about pamela
anderson then the story that she had
with her son yeah she sat her sons down
yeah she says listen you know she says
uh she's saying this in an interview she
said uh
uh uh
you know i uh
would go out and say i'm meeting
somebody and we end up having sex he
says many times i'm like what are you
doing
what do you do that does not feel good
you know hitting me here doesn't feel
good pulling my hair i don't like it
then i would ask the person whom i'm
having sex with i'd say hey how much
porn do you watch are you thinking that
you watch this in a video like a fetish
like it feels good for women so she was
teaching her sons what you see in porn
doesn't feel good that's acting and she
was kind of trying because she's saying
like porn is traumatized men to think
they have to
perform at that level and that's coming
from pamela anderson who i think's
probably been with more than one men in
her life i don't know the exact number
or treat women yeah disrespectfully
totally doesn't like that that was the
angle
there's a really good canadian
researcher on this called lily boiver
who you guys should have on as well
she's fascinating and she talks about
this where you know the number of men
who just wanted to choke her and slap
her just quite extreme
which not to say there aren't some
people who are consensually into those
things and that's fine but the sort of
expectation of those things which is and
she's done i can't remember the figures
because it's a few years since i
interviewed her but she's done research
that exposure to porn does increase you
know people having unrealistic
expectations of sort of fetishistic
behaviors that women will just be up for
that and you definitely don't want
you know you don't want your sons or or
indeed your daughters to be in this
situation where these are the sort of
that that's not that doesn't feel like a
liberated and healthy form of sex which
is what we want for young adults as they
start to develop you know i mean when
they get to the right age obviously
you we want people to have healthy
attitudes towards sex that are not based
around shame we don't in a funny way
those feel to me more like the old
attitudes this is where a lot of shame
in wanting to be aggressive and violent
and it feels to me like quite a
conflicted attitude towards sexuality
not for everyone i don't want to kink
shame anyone whatever people are into
conception
100 people who are into consensual
behavior anything you want to do
consensually with another adult um
knock yourself out literally if you want
but the
the um
but but i do think it's worth us
thinking about the ways in which massive
exposure to pornography for very young
people
i do think can have a distorting effect
on their sexuality that's unhealthy not
in every case but that's the only bit
i'm worried about consensual adults
nothing they do worries so if you
enjoyed this little short segment from
the podcast that we did here's another
short segment to watch or if you want to
see the entire podcast click over here
take care everybody bye
[Music]